welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and the a-holes of the marvel
cinematic universe now have an attorney
in law to be their devil's advocate in
she-hulk jennifer walters but too easy
to miss details from the second episode
now have me obsessed over the exact
nature of her work relationship with her
new boss at glk h holden holloway or is
mr holloway really her actual boss
because now we must ask what baddies
from across the mcu might jen have
knowingly consented to representing
let's look again closely at the moment
holloway recruits jen at the legalese
bar you may buy your drink well uh
sure i guess
can i help you yes there is more to this
moment than meets the eye i don't blame
you if you missed it the bartender holds
up a very specific bottle of bourbon
this is pappy van winkle a 23 year aged
bourbon that is extremely rare only a
few thousand of these bottles exist in
the world and online a single bottle can
run you over five thousand dollars with
a single shot in this bottle likely
costing several hundreds of dollars
seriously this bottle should be in that
tba drawer with the infinity stones
you're among makari's collection that is
why you'll notice we get the specific
close-up of the bartender giving a look
to holloway to make sure and holloway
gives him a nod clearly these two
pre-arranged to hook up jim with some
tippy top shelf liquor and for holloway
to spare no expense that's why he
doesn't really care whether or not jen
hires on her paralegal nicki and he sets
up jen with a plush corner office and
this sets up another interesting moment
that i keep rewatching from this episode
when holloway gives jen a tour of the
glk and h offices forcing her to hulk
out and parading her around you should
be able to enjoy the fact that i just
got an amazing new job and i can't but
i'm curious
what do you think about it
i'm
agnostic
interesting
unprecedented for sure
i'll spend the rest of the year worrying
about what i just said now i have talked
before about this show's interesting
specific choice of jen's fourth wall
breaking occurring in context so this is
not like when deadpool or zack morris or
malcolm or malcolm in the middle break
the fourth wall and no one around them
notices or reacts to them and their
worlds kind of freeze no this is
something closer to fleabag or the
moment wanda hears agatha behind the
camera jen talking to the camera has
real-time consequences within her world
she has to take a moment out of her day
as time continues to pass around her
characters notice her doing this and she
misses out on stuff in this case jen
just told her boss that she was agnostic
to some matter and that surprised him
now by agnostic she probably was not
referring to the religious definition of
agnostic but rather the more common
businessy legal definition as in she
isn't strictly set on any particular
opinion about something and she has an
open mind on the subject and based on
holloway's response it was something
that no one has ever had an open mind
about now in case you can't tell by the
shows i obsess over i love adventure the
bigger the better but chase through a
city okay not bad an evil force is going
to destroy the planet all right now
we're getting somewhere the interstellar
fate of humanity hangs in the balance
now that's more like it astro kings is a
real time multiplayer sci-fi mobile game
that puts you in charge of the fate of
humanity it's up to you to rebuild your
civilization after an enemy force
invades your home world and build up a
fleet of starships that'll make all the
aliens pirates and other intergalactic
bozos wish they had never opened up
their star charts you can harvest
materials research technology and
recruit heroes from all over the galaxy
to make sure that your civilization
lasts and if you really want to take it
to the next level you can create an
embassy and join a galactic federation
to team with other players immerse
yourself in cinematic 3d graphics and
epic mmo and pvp battles and right now
astro kings is celebrating its four year
anniversary from now until august 30th
there will be special pirates and pirate
bases spawning in the universe you'll
get the double item drops during the
weekend plus a chance to get a free
spaceship in heroes download astro kings
by clicking the link in the description
or by scanning the qr code use the
exclusive code ak4th
and claim the special anniversary
rewards the universe is infinite and the
adventure in astro kings is never ending
so get on it now i've rewatched this
clip a dozen times and it is impossible
to make out what holloway is saying
under jen's dialogue his head faces away
from camera for most of the walk he does
lean into brain briefly but his mouth
doesn't form any discernible word
however as jen reacts to the dodos
laughing in the conference room we do
hear holloway's voice briefly cut in
there
these dodos never had to deal with this
on their first day at work yeah for some
reason holloway says oh money money
money money now while you could write
this off as maybe the things in jen's
point of view are heard by his
perspective including the comic
overacting of the dudes in the
conference room but i don't know
she-hulk hasn't really shifted reality
quite like that before i think these
conference room dudes are laughing like
that and holloway did say the words
money money money money for some reason
but either way it sounds like this
moment set up a mystery that we're gonna
answer throughout the season all the
weird and controversial clients that jen
has accidentally agreed to take on as
clients now jen walters has represented
some controversial figures in the comics
including a 2006 storyline in which jen
represents arrows aka star fox in a
sexual assault case i know i know this
was one reason i was shocked marvel
studios ever brought in arrows into the
mcu maybe they assumed the beloved harry
styles could pull off the role in a way
no one would really criticize so did she
hulk accidentally just say she was
agnostic about this kind of arrow's case
doubtful in the mcu eros is definitely
still off-world and i just really don't
think marvel studios would right now bog
this character down in the american
legal system with this super
uncomfortable storyline also i don't
know if disney plus shows can handle
that kind of watermelon sugar i'm
referring to how much money it would
cost to book a world famous pop star get
your mind out of the gutter viewer but
clearly the context of holloway's
question was money it seems like his
question to jen was seeking her thoughts
on whether it was ethical for a law firm
to create an entire division using money
from a morally cloudy source it must be
that because yet jen gets a swanky
office and holloway was willing to drop
several g's on 23 year old bourbon to
get her to sign on the line that is
dotted and the word unprecedented must
have referred to how much money holloway
took who he was taking it from and what
that source is tasking his firm to do
and obviously there are a few options
for wealthy crooks active in the mcu in
this moment that could be bankrolling
glk and h and many of those quirks might
actually be working together since matt
murdock has confirmed to tie into this
series we have to look at wilson fisk
maya lopez shot him in the eye in
hawkeye but based on that happening
off-screen and his outfit signaling that
they're probably adapting that comic run
where fisk recovers from getting his eye
shot out by echo our boy wilson
definitely survived and yeah he is
confirmed to return and daredevil born
again on disney plus so this she-hulk
series could reveal that it is fisk or
maybe the fisk estate one of his shell
companies using glk and h to liberate
various super villains so that fisk
could have leverage over these bad guys
as his own personal hired guns and we
also know a similar process is occurring
with val she is recruiting super
assassins like john walker and elena
pilova most likely leading to the
thunderbolts val seems to represent some
shadowy government agency and if so
we're talking about the us government
they literally print their own money so
the unprecedented aspect that holloway
referred to could be this law firm
taking cash from one government agency
to lobby against a more public state
authority the dodc to subvert their
interests i actually think it's possible
that wilson fisk and val are two sides
of the same coin val representing the
deep state backdoor legal arm of the
thunderbolts operation fisk providing
the funding for it both of them
benefiting from having a disposable team
of dark avengers to deploy on whatever
horrible objective they want to
accomplish so star attorney jennifer
walters could provide them some legal
cover to try to exonerate criminals like
john walker or wilson fist this of
course would be before jen probably gets
wise to how she's being exploited and i
suspect by the end of the season parts
ways with glk h and launches her own
firm hopefully with nelson and murdock
now while this she-hulk series is
promising a pretty deep bench of cameos
from wong to daredevil it remains to be
seen whether these will include kingpin
val john walker or of course our daddy
methisto but as an attorney in law of
the mcu she-hulk can now make charlie
cox in no way home-sized cameos in any
future marvel title where characters
need some legal aid but just some advice
to jen and maybe steer clear of the
eternal starship you don't need to get
your hands dirty with that hey you can
follow me on tick-tock instagram and
twitter at avos subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and a reminder to
download astro kings now and begin your
epic sci-fi adventure today don't forget
to use the exclusive code ak4th and
claim your special anniversary rewards
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you